okay I'm Steve Anderson I was previously
the chair of
Yale which will turn out to be relevant
and it's my pleasure to introduce Gerald
Shea Jerry is not either a linguist or a
psychologist and so perhaps it's useful
for me to give a little background when
I was chaired nearly in fact almost
exactly eight years ago I received in
the mail a manuscript from someone I
didn't know about a topic that about
which I didn't know very much I'm sure
Bob Frank as current chair will confirm
the fact that we get lots of the chair
of linguistics at Yale gets lots of
things and some of them are a little
unusual but this one seemed to it to be
worth a lot more attention and not only
because the author was a Yalie ba 64 the
the manuscript I had which was called
language of light no it was called song
without words was interesting for for
two somewhat different reasons on the
one hand it described the experience of
someone whose language experience is
rather different from any of the ones
that cognitive scientists tend to study
on the one hand we study hearing people
who learn spoken languages and on the
other hand we study deaf people who
learn sign languages but here was the
experience of someone who had lost a
great deal of his hearing at a very
early age but that fact hadn't actually
been properly diagnosed until much later
in life and he succeeded in the hearing
community despite his hearing deficit
getting through Yale and getting through
Columbia Law School this it seemed to me
it was a situation that cognitive
science ought to pay attention to it's
rather unusual to characterize the
linguistic experience of someone
functioning in a spoken language who has
actually very limited access to speech
as a consequence of hearing deficit so
on the one hand that struck me as a an
interesting problem for cognitive
scientists on the other hand the book
contained a great deal of really
interesting information about the
history of the emergence and development
of signed language in France which as we
know is the background out of which ASL
comes work that was based on Jerry's
work in libraries and Archives in France
and which taught me a great deal I mean
I'd done some reading on this background
but I learned a lot from looking at this
manuscript so I was happy to encourage
it and to recommend it for publication
and to provide some comments especially
on the linguistic aspects as I say Jerry
isn't a linguist and there were some
some things that I thought needed a
little bit of commentary but then the in
2013 the book was published as song
without words the book is lovely an
eloquent book if you haven't read it you
surely should but when I saw what came
out in print I was somewhat less happy
at the fact that all this stuff about
the science of sign and the history had
been omitted and this was almost
entirely about Jerry's experience as a
partially hearing person well I talked
to him about this and he said that I was
because the publishers wanted this to be
a general audience book and they said
take all that science and history stuff
out of it they'll people will like it
more if it's if it's just lovely
experience and it is a wonderful book
but I'm afraid that because that
material was omitted its attracted less
attention from linguists and cognitive
scientists than perhaps it ought to have
but anyway I was very happy a few years
later when I heard from Jerry that he
was interested in taking the material
from his original manuscript that hadn't
been included expanding it and
publishing that as a separate book so I
was happy to put him in touch with
people at Yale University Press
the result is an absolutely wonderful
book on the historical origins and
development of signed languages and
signed language and the deaf community
in France and subsequently in this
country if you haven't read language of
light then you should certainly read
that one too so without further ado I
will turn this over to Jerry who will I
gather be giving you material mostly
from the second book thank you thank you
very much Steve and thank you all for
coming I think I'll take this device off
and thanks to Raphael there's an rotini
for organized under staff for organizing
this conference so a Blee and it's
really a delight to be here as it was to
hear the two prior speakers I learned a
lot in the first hour and a half of
today as Steve explained I first became
familiar with the history and languages
of the Deaf when I was looking for
information about the partially deaf
from my first book the memoir that Steve
mentioned as I discussed at length in
that book I am partially deaf a
condition that arose following an
extended childhood illness when others
speak here an elusive language to which
in the rapid course of conversation I
endeavor to give meaning the words of
this language what I call its lyrical z'
the term of my invention are
transitional words wrong words non words
that in lieu of those actually spoken
register in the minds of the partially
deaf the high-frequency and soft
consonants are usually missing the
vowels and the occasional consonant
aren't enough and my life and the lives
of the partially deaf like me are a
constant unscrambling of language
punctuated by masks
understanding I communicate fairly
effectively using the hearing I've
retained lip-reading hearing aids and an
assortment of assistive listening
devices
there's no time here to dwell on my
history it's all in song without words
if you want to buy it on Amazon and it's
all in there when I finally did get
hearing aids late at age 34 a lot of
sounds came back to me that were the
sounds of childhood crickets birds not
seagulls which they always heard but you
know birds twittering in the air
Piccolo's high stringed instruments that
brought the melody back to music for me
rather than the than the counterpoint of
low low instruments as to water water is
a beautiful sound and when I was
presenting the book at a gathering in
London the first book song without words
a reporter Haley Campbell from the New
Statesman came up to me and said hey
tell me something that I haven't you
know that's not the critics don't talk
about it that nobody knows about it and
I said well I'll tell you a little bit
about water when I got hearing aids the
first day I got him I went off to pee
and I had him on and it was the first
time I realized since childhood I get
but I'd forgotten that that when you pee
it actually makes a sound so Haley
Campbell in the new States he liked that
and in the New Statesman these aren't my
words of course they're hers she said
imagine what it would be like going
through life without knowing what piss
sounded like this this room scares me to
death
one more anecdote I think I was in this
room the very first lecture I was at
Yale and the teacher started to speak I
don't know what probably history
something easy and the when he started
to speak everybody picked up their pen
and pencil and of course I could hear
his voice and a few words but
they were actually starting to write and
I thought this must be a very good
University
since the students is so Brighton so my
theme song might have been something
like Gaudi Elmo's eg tour since we can't
even hear the teachers I have no fluent
moving on to the history now I have no
fluent understanding of the signed
languages of the profoundly deaf but the
Grace and visual clarity of those who
communicated in sign languages as you
have just seen and as you are seeing now
are to me a wonder and I feel a close
affinity to it and to them theirs is not
an unplanned but a natural visual poetry
at once both the speech and the music of
the deaf though I live in the realm of
the hearing a part of my life in the
form of my search for communicative
grace and clarity is quartered in my
understanding of the world of the deaf
and I feel as if a part of it as I
mentioned I originally became familiar
with the history and languages of the
Deaf when I was looking for information
about people like me
I found that history so rich and
intriguing and fraught with pathos that
I decided to write about it the language
of light my book covers a long history
from the Classical period through our
own day in about 200 pages I can't talk
all about about all of that in half an
hour
thus I'd like to focus on what I
consider the centerpiece of the history
of the Deaf and side languages ie the
accomplishments of the great French
teachers of the early 19th century
notably Auguste baby all this is also
the heart of the book I call this period
the Enlightenment or the age of baby ohm
but I'll also mention in unforgivably
nutshell form the time before and the
time after that era the age of baby all
as we shall see was an island of
eloquence and wisdom in a wide rapidly
running river of ignorance and prejudice
on the part of the hearing a brief note
first on what history and
linguistics have taught about it saw us
about sign languages and we've heard
much of that this morning a children
born profoundly deaf
of course here virtually nothing at all
they're unable to speak because their
ears can't transmit to the brain the
information it needs to shape the
imitative speaking patterns of the voice
these children then turn instinctively
to gestures in order to communicate with
others they do so extraordinarily and
efficiently once they are exposed to a
sign language which they learn quickly
and naturally they're very soon exactly
they've they're very soon able exactly
like their hearing counterparts to
express a limit of limitless number of
ideas in well-formed sentences with
impeccable syntax the discourse of the
Deaf is not and as in the case of spoken
languages configured by the tongue and
other organs of speech arranging
molecules in the air for the ear but by
the motion of hands at other gestures
that are transmitted by light to the
eyes of their interlocutors hence my
title the language of light sign
languages are just as sophisticated as
our spoken tongues they have their own
linguistic units just as our oral
languages do when deaf individuals
render or interpret signs they use the
same regions of the brain that the
hearing do when they speak and listen to
speech they are hearing their language
there is little historical record of the
deaf or their languages before the
sixteenth century but sign languages in
various forms and degrees of
sophistication have probably existed for
at the very least under a thousand years
for as long as mankind and thus have
deaf people sign languages were not
invented by anyone nor was French
English or German so the time before
baby on Aristotle found the blind more
intelligent than the Deaf because the
blind could hear
he believed that all rational discourse
had to be audible st. Agustin thought
deaf people could never learn to read
the Justinian code in 522 provided that
of a person with death from birth and
couldn't speak
he had virtually no rights deidre
thought that to teach the deaf
abstractions was an insurmountable task
Juan Pablo Bonet in the 17th century
Spain called the congenitally deaf
monsters of nature and human only inform
his goal was to cure them by teaching
them how to speak he failed of course as
did all of his Spanish British Dutch
French German and American oralist
successors it was virtually impossible
for a person to speak distinctly if
since birth were early infancy he or she
had not been able to hear lip-reading is
just as difficult while I and other
partially deaf people lip read a bit you
have to be able to hear in order to do
it well or as well as as well as we do
which is not very well so forget about
all those deaf characters reading lips
for the CIA and those movies you see
through the medically sealed windows and
the telescope they're just reciting a
script that they've memorized I did tho
manage to do it once I was watching Bill
Clinton was playing golf with Greg
Norman I think or that you know straw
hat and there was a party afterwards in
somewhere in the States and Clinton
stepped backwards and fell over the
porch and broke his leg and they wheeled
him out to Air Force One to set the leg
in Washington the leg was sticking out
and it was a two kilometers out and the
tarmac but the cameras with their big
lenses were there watching him but no
sound and Clinton said
now the first three words are clear
right what what the f are the first
three words but what's the rest what is
now no one in this room has an idea but
it anybody I'm some sometimes with
context you can get it and what he said
was what the f are those photographers
doing there so I was very very proud of
myself but it was you know a
once-in-a-lifetime event so what should
Monet think about sign language he said
if you place two deaf mutes in each
other's presence meeting for the first
time they can communicate because they
use the same science Bob Lee dick too
but he like others was not interested in
trying to understand these signs or to
ask himself what the Deaf were saying to
each other or where their signs came
from or whether these communications
might be a form of language indeed
because it interfered with their
learning the speech they weren't
learning he found it important as the
last many speech therapists and doctors
do today quote never to let the mute use
it unquote
torturous so-called medical treatments
when hand in hand with the tyranny of
oral teaching in the centuries before
the Enlightenment
he's amounted to trials by ordeal
yielding considerable suffering illness
and sometimes death the premise was that
drilling cutting fracturing scorching or
poisoning would open up the ear and the
brain to sounds it was into this aural
world that arrived the Abid lay pay a
hearing priest about to make history
observing deaf twin girls signing to
each other in 1755 he suspected that
their signs were mutually recognizable
representations of ideas going a step
further he wondered whether justice
hearing children are taught to write
what they hear so these children might
be taught to write what they see
ie to be taught in their own science the
meaning of written words and to learn
how to read and write
those words they pay established to
school for the Deaf in Paris in 1755 and
the royal government ultimately granted
him a substantial annual stipend to run
it but for all his perceptiveness it was
the first time anybody had done this
they paid didn't become fluent in signs
and never understood it was a complete
language he gave the students his own
supplementary signs rather than learning
from them and mastering their own
integral tongue he died in 1789 but in
1794 the government gave his school its
imposing home on the Rue saint-jacques
where it is today the National Institute
for deaf children called sanjeok it was
to become and today remains the beacon
of the age of the Enlightenment Oh goose
baby ah who was hearing and perhaps
history's greatest teacher of the Deaf
was born the year they pay died he was
sent by his father from Guadeloupe where
he was born to study at the lycée Shalom
Anya in Paris his parents were friends
of the director of sanjeok who offered
to find a place for him to live babe you
live near the school and in the
afternoons and during the the vacations
he was constantly there joining the deaf
students in their classes workshops and
games although hearing he made friends
with several of the deaf students and
thanks to Jean Monsieur a noted deaf
teacher there learned to sign as well as
those who were deaf from birth an
unprecedented accomplishment baby ons
writings and teachings were to become
the cornerstone of the education of the
Deaf in Europe and of the Deaf in the
United States what was needed he
realized in order to teach his students
to read and write was the immediate
translation of their own thoughts and
images as expressed in their own
language into the corresponding written
words in French central to his thought
and teaching is the reality that words
are but the expression of pre-existing
ideas an idea whether the conception of
a material object
or an abstract thought necessarily
precedes the spoken word interpreting it
is us the idea he wrote that must give
the word meaning before the word can in
turn become an effective interpreter of
the idea or what John Locke had
interestingly called interestingly
called the sign of the ideal the hearing
ordinarily conveyed their thoughts by
speaking the poor bore writing down
words made of letters that are
depictions of the sound we make with our
voices what babe you know they'd be all
eloquently called the painting of our
speech while students arriving at
sanjeok would have at least the
rudiments of sign baby on in his
practical teaching manual hypothesized
the case of a new student at sanjeok in
order to illustrate for parents and
teachers that evening that even the
teaching of individual words should
begin with the thought not the written
word the teacher might show the picture
of a sabre in a book and then move his
dominant hand from opposite waist to
shoulder-high as if drawing a saber from
a sheath exaggerating the sign remember
they're not recognizably iconic and the
student would invariably do the same
baby of an unsheathed the imaginary
saber again and have the students show
him its picture in the book whereupon he
would point to the written word beneath
the picture he would then have the
student fingerspell the word if he knew
fingerspelling and ask him and sign what
the word meant what the student would
then repeat the gesture and before long
would understand that this written word
and others were a kind of conventional
drawing of the idea first expressed in
sign as two ideas expressed in whole
sentences baby or knew that the apparent
goal before his time a Barrett goal
before his time and continuing to his
own day was to give to the deaf and I
quote the mechanical Faculty of speech
without enabling them to attach a
precise idea to its components leaving
em in the dark not only as to the
absolute value of words but their
relative value and the influence they
have over each
other in the composition of a phrase
hence the drill even today of parents
and speech therapists hammering home the
pronunciation and lip-reading of
multiple words by deaf children have a
necessity got things backwards for
without sign language it is difficult if
not impossible to convey ideas and
syntax and whole meanings of sentences
baby all Dells correctly emphasized that
French grammar which he described as the
relationship between words and our
spoken languages had to be taught
through the medium of sign language he
said this deaf student must be able to
write the word in order to read it and
to be able to read it he has to
understand it and he'll be able to
understand it only if he only if he
understands the whole sentence to do
that his instruction must begin in sign
writing for the deaf prima facia
represented nothing at all it consists
of lines or strokes forming meaningless
characters more complex than their
painting of sounds for the hearing and
far more removed from the underlying
idea than its expression in their native
language and in trying to read lips the
Deaf are not receiving any idea but are
forced to observe obscure lip movements
movements in order to guess sounds they
cannot hear so that so that they may
infer the other sounds that the lips
failed to show at all the mental torture
of Bonet and is oralist successors if
the Deaf student baby on rote is brought
to a standstill to begin with with by
the singular difficulty of pronouncing
sounds of which the signs fixed on paper
life stationary before his eyes how is
he going to understand the rapid signs
that slipped through the lips it is with
their own language that the education of
the Deaf must begin not with the spoken
word
we know baby I wrote that the deaf have
a language one doesn't teach them
although with art and exercise one can
offer it the happiest development it is
in a way the reflection of their
sensations the relief of their
impressions we carried the same timeless
and limitless principle within all of us
that of the first language of any human
being which gives immediate expression
to his thought and is not a translation
of any other language but expresses his
intimate connection with ideas one ever
looks to his first language with
difficulty for the expression of an idea
the thought born in the brain bursts
forth like a flame sparkling in crystal
how effective was baby ohm in 1789 at
the time of lei pays death there were
six schools for the Deaf in France by
1858 there were 54 such schools and sign
was the language of instruction and all
of them a significant number of teachers
of the Deaf were deaf themselves deaf
education and literacy were springing up
everywhere with deaf children in Europe
reading a scene servantes Gertz and
Pushkin as well as the goostin Augustin
spiritual dimensions proclaiming that
the Deaf would never be able to read the
very book they were reading or any other
on the more practical side the potential
of the Deaf in the Arts and Sciences and
commerce were now realizable and signed
languages were becoming the motor of
their Equality together baby oh and his
deaf colleagues and students were
changing the world
students were entering the professions
of the hearing including work in lawyers
offices banks trading companies etc some
were accomplished painters and poets it
wasn't a perfect world but now they had
two languages French sign language and
the written and European sign language
language as pardon me and the written
language of the hearing they were
succeeding in the hearing world and what
happened in America well we were of
course seeking solutions to and in 1816
as most of us here know Thomas Gallaudet
of Hartford came to
Frantz looking for one a solution
leaving London after the British wanted
to charge him for teaching teaching him
they're ineffective oral methods which
they maintained were secret
he went to sanjeok and took back to the
states with him a prominent deaf teacher
named Lahaul Clare clarin Gallaudet
brought maybe else teaching with them to
the United States with which they formed
the deaf core of American teachers
English immigrants had given us our
spoken and written language but the
French in the person of law Clare
enriched American Sign Language with
French sign and used the new combined
language ASL to teach the American deaf
the written language of France's rival
across the channel by the 1850s some 250
of the 550 teachers and administrators
in the burgeoning national network of
schools were themselves deaf by the
1860s there were 26 schools and sign was
the language of instruction of all but
for a variety of reasons the champions
of speech teaching would never let go
baby owns deaf pupil failed in our
belchy the greatest deaf teacher of the
Deaf and deaf leader of the 19th century
was well aware of it he did a lot to try
to stop it he one of the most beautiful
things beautiful things he did I think
was to organize annual deaf banquets
that were held all around Paris between
1832 and 1869 or so and he invited the
greats to come Daguerre Vittorio
Lamartine and many others and like today
he had children of deaf parents who were
hearing do the interpreting so that
everybody could understand everybody
else just as we are doing today Peltier
was also a poet the and I'll quote this
poem because I love it it's it's much
better than my English translation but
here goes as background the Phoenician
alphabet about 1000 BC is the source of
virtually all modern alphabets Betty
himself
refer to this point in his own poem
pronouncing in sign language and
interpret by an another at one of these
banquets here it is we do not speak it
is true but still do you think us unable
to express ourselves as well with our
eyes our hands our smiles our lips our
most beautiful discourse is that the
tips of our fingers and our language is
rich in secret beauties that you who
speak will never know and have we not
have we not our own art of Phoenicia to
paint the words that speak into our eyes
your Arts and Sciences save for sound
are they not open to our ardent minds
show us the heavens ambitious heirs of
Icarus that I cannot ascend with you but
as I say BRCA was well aware of the
forces against him he warned his
colleagues and students alike that if
they didn't fight for their education in
their own language they would lose
everything after baby on the 19th
century oralist movement deliberately
set out to destroy the languages and
educational institutions of the deaf in
effect the movement all but ruined the
extraordinary accomplishments of the
great European and American teachers of
the earlier part of the century the
oralists were led by Alexander Graham
Bell and by hearing teachers of the Deaf
and others in Europe and the United
States at the 1880 Congress of Milan as
many of us here know a gathering of
hearing educators went with little
knowledge of sign languages the Assembly
proudly proclaimed the incontestable
superiority of speech over sign and
resolve the deaf students should be
taught only by the pure oral method
before long throughout Europe speech
became virtually the sole method of
teaching by requiring deaf
students to hear or lip read and to
speak impossible tasks virtually
impossible tasks Milan made sole faculty
thus to Milan made the sole faculty
these students lacked the instrument of
their instruction what was the motive of
the oralists why insist on teaching a
child words he couldn't speak and
staring at lips he couldn't understand
for some notably the oral teachers the
motive was the desire to keep their jobs
as to Bell he conceded that sign
language was the quickest method of
reaching the mind of a deaf child but it
was not the mind of the deaf child that
interested Bell quote the production of
a defective race of signing human beings
he wrote would be a great calamity to
the world if they were deprived of their
language of signs the Deaf would be
unable to understand not only the
hearing but each other they would marry
less fewer children and their number
would diminish even Bell's prejudiced
ideas about eugenics were without
foundation for as mentioned earlier
about 95% of children born deaf then and
today are bored of hearing parents Bell
and his allies were extraordinarily
successful in 1867 American language
language had been the medium of
instruction in all educational
institutions for the Deaf by 1927 it was
used in virtually none deaf students
were graduating from Orla schools in
Europe and America as functional
illiterate in the written languages of
their native countries Gallaudet college
was discouraging its students from
becoming teachers in France the country
of baby owned as recently as 215 2015
a prominent ear surgeon wrote in the
figa Howe that quote speech is the only
language the brain can
comprehend unquote finally some brighter
signs the eminent linguist noam chomsky
giving a lecture in Chicago in 1965
mistakenly that's a rare a Chomsky
mistake
defined language as a specific sound -
meaning correspondence when asked where
this left the signed languages of the
Deaf Chomsky revised his definition on
the spot
calling language a specific signal -
meaning correspondence the distinction
was important for it offered it was
offered at a time when William Stokoe
and his colleagues at Gallaudet
University were rediscovering they were
rediscovering what had been known in
France and America in the early 19th
century much of what Stokey wrote about
linguistics was really taking from baby
ons own writings Stokey gave him credit
it wasn't very conspicuous credit but he
did give baby on credit so these ideas
that are coming up today they're not new
ideas these were ideas that were
developed in the early 19th century and
were suppressed with the money of Bell
in the United States with the / Ayers in
Europe with the help of the oralist
teachers and the oralist movement and
they basically smothered what we knew so
much so the owner people rediscovered it
in the 20th century they thought they
were discovering something new and they
weren't Chomsky's work and the work of
Stokey and his successors were of
exceptional significance this was not so
this was so not simply because the
hearing world had forgotten what it had
known by the 1820s but because of the
calamitous success as I just said our
people are I'm repeating myself of the
oralist movement have the thoughts and
work of Chomsky stokke and others now
help to overcome the educational plight
of the deaf
they have unquestionably led to a
renaissance of linguistic and
educational interest in sign languages
giving new life including now our
academic life
here at Yale to the seminal work of baby
ohm it is now broadly understood the
Chomsky's language faculty operates with
equal facility whether stimulated by
language heard by the years of the
hearing or beheld by the eyes of the
Deaf the primitive notions of the Deaf
and their language espoused at Milan and
promoted by Bell are now rather
thoroughly discredited but the
educational problems of the death
persist today 80% of newborn deaf babies
in the West are being given cochlear
implants the implants are devices as
most of us know that produce hearing
bypassing the ear and delivering
electronic signals directly to the
auditory nerve the benefits of cochlear
implants are measured today in
laboratory setting and alas appear to
fall far short outside of that setting
thus the real world of daily
communication is still a struggle
despite the device notably for children
who were born deaf language can be said
to give us all of us whether the deaf or
hearing whether deaf or hearing our
modern soul in the age of science and
underpin our rights as individuals
whether that soul will can best be
expressed and understood and can best
understand the world around it in its
natural language or with cochlear
implants or perhaps both is the heart
and soul of the matter is a smaller
fully communicative world preferable to
a larger poorly communicative one is
they're both worlds alternatives are the
implants a paradigm attic change or are
they an extension of the dramatic course
of 19th and 20th century deaf history
and of earlier times there are variety
views on these hotly debated questions
my own views are shaped the
my own research by a careful study of
published test results and naturally
enough by my intimate acquaintance with
the history I propose no answers here
but whatever the answers it is
critically important that we assure that
these children born deaf be given the
opportunity to learn as soon as possible
in life what is their own their first
their natural language and evocation of
the soul itself thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much we now have some
time for questions I suggest that we
turn your question period into the
question period for right for everyone
so please feel free to ask questions for
our last speaker but also for the other
two panelists okay we have two
microphones that will run up and down
the aisles to receive your questions
okay
Siri we have a question here
hi thank you all for speaking today it
was good to write um anyone can answer
this but it's a question regarding
language ah it louder oh it's a question
regarding language acquisition um I was
wondering
like we're talking about in class most
if not all users of sign are bilingual
they have their language of sign and
also their written language because the
sign language doesn't have its over in
form I'm so far the acquisition
processes for these different and what
can you guys speak to your personal
experiences with this or because there
is an understanding of an import filter
for language but does it work
differently for sign versus writing I
think the question is is the acquisition
process design language different from
the language acquisition process in
spoken languages no for when you are
learning how to write the written
language because there's like written
English language versus the sign
language so most users of sign are
bilingual in that sense so is a language
acquisition process for that different
and how does that work I can speak a
little bit to that
I don't specialize in literacy of deaf
children but I do know a little bit
about the research that exists there are
studies a great deal of studies looking
at that so there are we know deaf
students who are very successful in
terms of literacy skills the question is
how do they become such good readers and
how do they become literate in a written
language that does not apply to their
sign language abilities it's entirely
separate because because the laying the
the written language is not tracked with
the sign language that they use let me
just back up for just a minute for
hearing children learning a spoken
language tracks with the written
language that they also learned and
there's much research that shows
phonological knowledge of language
really boosts the
to learn to read and write so a lot of
length language literacy instruction has
to do with phonology and how that plays
into learning to read and write so that
phonology does not map of a written
language does not map onto a sign
language used by deaf students research
today is looking at how deaf students
may capitalize on the phonology of their
sign language to assist in the process
or support the process of learning to
read and write not all of the literacy
applies to deaf children in this area
but there are some findings that we can
apply to the situation in fall in deaf
education so there's some evidence that
the morphology of sign languages in what
having phonology a foundation in one
language can be used to enhance the
language learning process in literacy of
a second language I'd like to add one
thing to what amber said so every child
regardless if they're learning a spoken
language or sign language has to be
taught how to read and write the writing
systems aren't universal they're a
cultural invention so it's always the
case that the process of learning how to
read and write is different from
language acquisition so the question is
how is it different for sign language
visual language users versus spoken
language users because there's not a
one-to-one mapping in phonological form
and that's the research question that we
have not yet well that we're still
looking at now it's a it's a current
area of research as to as to syntax baby
I made the wonderful point in teaching
kids that he would first go through the
notion of a sentence this table I strike
I think in those days ah I don't know
whether it's the case now but the
sentence would often begin with the
object so a sign science signing student
would be signed by baby on this table I
strike he makes sure the student got the
idea and then having been through the
exercise of teaching
child words and sentences he would say
well when you write it down you don't
write this table I strike you're right I
strike this table this is the way these
crazy hearing people do it and so that's
he was quite good I think at getting
that getting syntax and grammar through
to those kids is a question next to you
[Music]
a friend of mine online was upset with
the Consular marketing where children
were not supposed to be taught sign she
herself was deaf and she was very
offended with this and I can certainly
understand her attitude towards genocide
but the yards what did you say mm-hmm
Jennifer that's where you exterminate
the entire culture that's what the cost
of people early on we're trying to do
it's a natural very typical natural
asinine sort of thing people do they
wanted to help people so of course they
had to exterminate other efforts to help
but looking into this I it looks to me
as though baby sign is very beneficial
to the intellectual and spiritual
development of small children at a very
important age of development a child who
can express themselves at the age of one
is going to be developing rhetorical
abilities of an entire year before most
children can make noises come out of
their faces but now this evening I
understand baby sign could be
significant towards the training of
future engineers because of the spatial
aspect then I say that very seriously a
moment ago we were talking about the
inadequacies of written language to
which I would respond that there is also
a subject
rafting which is could expand written
language could be seen as expanding
written language in the direction of
spatial orientation so it seems to me
that baby sign is a very important
subject and it the sign language should
not be confined to special education or
linguistic Rarity's but should be
learned by every parent beyond that I
would like to know how do I say
Nicaragua there seems to be very
important to see think Nicaragua how do
you say what Nicaragua Oh Nicaragua
is a simple question how do we say
Nicaragua and a longer question about
the importance of signs if you're asking
a specific question about baby sign I
can't answer that without first saying
that we can't talk about baby signs for
hearing children oops unless we also are
talking about education at teaching sign
language deaf children so I would say
issues about teaching hearing infants to
sign okay that's an individual decision
for parents to make but we can't talk
about that first I think first we need
to address the fact that deaf children
need to have equal opportunities that's
where the focus needs to be first this
is the sign for Nicaragua Nicaragua in
in NSL
[Laughter]
I have a question for giclee for dr.
Martin and an colleagues about the
origin
relationship between the origins of
language and spatial works so one of the
interesting things in the archaeological
record is that with the stone tools
traditions we see stone tools from a
couple of million years ago and they're
unchanged unchanged unchanged and then
we get by facial blades they're called
so we get symmetrical stone flakes and
then they change they stay unchanged
unchanging change and so on for another
half a million years and then we see a
stone tool specialization we see
different shapes of tools and so on so
of course the production of the by
facial blades the the ones with the the
chips on either side requires being able
to manipulate tools and think about
symmetry at the same time so I'm
wondering if if you see that as a
potential clue to language development
or whether it's the something like the
later proliferation of of stone tools
and the variation and so on which might
be more indicative or is there any
thoughts you have on this matter would
be great honestly I'm not sure exactly
what you're asking you're talking about
comparing the development of those two
things over time in the emergence of a
language and how spatial ideas like
symmetry and things like that how they
influence and shape language is that
what you're addressing it's more the
question related to dr. cokeheads point
about language about tracing language
origins and I guess cultural evolution
and a biological evolution of of
language so we see these I guess
evidence we see pieces of evidence for
cultural development of millions of
years but yet the work on Nicaraguans
my language suggests that language
development for these kids is very quick
within what two generations or three
three generations so I'm wondering what
lessons we can learn about reading back
contemporary situations back into the
the remote past yeah that's kind of how
I feel about it too I have some thoughts
I'm not sure though if my thoughts will
actually answer your question but would
you like to take a shot at that amory
something that comes to mind for me is
and I'm not sure if this is exactly what
you're asking
part of what dr. Koch have talked about
in terms of cognitive tools and
resources that we have those may have
appeared long long ago and those are
might be things that we can take
advantage of to create language so the
languages that we create must those
cognitive resources must be in place for
that to occur so the emergence of
spatial language and how it emerges for
example we see that for people learning
sign language well for all people
hearing or deaf there are strengths and
weaknesses in terms of mental rotation
capabilities what some of us are good at
strengths that we bring to the table
come into play when we think about human
beings for those who talk about other
things have other strengths and
weaknesses there may be something about
the language except itself that uses
certain skills to incorporate in the
development of the language in the first
place
so the the kind of thing that you might
be talking about is where long long ago
historically perhaps a cognitive ability
emerged at some point in the history of
human development and then there comes a
time where language is needed to
capitalize on something to to be able to
do something and then that feeds back
into the development of the language as
a cycle that's the type of thing I'm
thinking about I'm not sure if it
addresses what you're interested in
knowing about but those are my thoughts
I'm also not completely sure what the
question was was it well so you said
that tools started out as one thing and
then at some point there was a point
where they became widespread and
specialized and you're asking if that
parallels the what we're seeing in
language emergence was that the question
you were asking or are you talking about
Chomsky's proposal for single mutation
changes that allows for our language
faculty yeah so I guess the the question
I guess not exactly I guess it's the
answer to that so the we have in in the
biological versus the cultural ideas
about evolution of language this
gradualist idea that we build up
cultural scaffolding from communication
systems which are non linguistic like or
protein linguistic like or or something
like that but we also have this
biological capacity for language which
is which is presumably relatively abrupt
if it's a single gene mutation it's the
the time it takes for that to to
percolate through a population which is
are actually having trouble hearing you
your mic keeps dropping out it seems and
so they're having difficulty
understanding the question that you're
asking
and then can't interpret it correctly oh
okay yeah and sorry
is that is that better if I hold it a
bit a bit closer okay yes yes also maybe
my accent I have an Australian accent so
and also a call and it's a complicated a
complicated topic as well so I guess we
have this biological abruptness versus
cultural gradualism on and some
interplay of the of the two and I think
dr. Coco you have made that very clear
in in your talk to start the afternoon
but we also have this this work in the
cultural evolution literature and the
cognitive evolution literature on these
spatial manipulation evolution of
spatial manipulation evolution of stone
tools and and the combination of the
learning of how to make stone tools and
the cognitive capacity for just doing
the manipulation to make the the chips
that we need to make in the first place
they're just doing the manipulation of
the stone to make the the tools and it
was just striking to me that your two
talks together brought up many of these
points that that come come to debates in
this in this literature so yes I was
interested in in discussing that further
but but I agree it's a very complex
topic and if we had answers here we
could all go home I think we have time
for one more question mr. Shea and
you're striking book the language of
light one of the more striking aspects
of the story of deaf education to me
anyway was the role of Helen Keller in
that story you want to tell that a
little bit about that the answer would
be a long one I'll try to make it short
Helen Keller was remarkable she was deaf
and blind from the age of about seven
and she got all the way through
Radcliffe
but there is disappointing evidence in
the history that at a young age work
that was presented as her own was in
fact plagiarized by Ann Sullivan from a
and it was great crisis in Helens life
the head of the Perkins School in Boston
disowned her and in effect and she
ultimately recovered from that many
people jump to her defense he was only a
child of course but there is some
thought that much much of her writing in
later life may have been written in
large part by others whether it was or
not she was brilliant she did get
through Radcliffe and accomplished a lot
but one of the problems I think Helen
always had she never learned how to
speak she well audibly
she never learned how to read lips
whether read lips by touch but Alexander
Graham Bell used her as a kind of
advertisement for oralist teaching and
his his favorite phrase was well if
blind and deaf Helen Keller can speak
and read lips well why can't and learn
so much why can't the deaf who were not
blind accomplice time but lots of what
he said about Helen was force was false
it also turns out in history that when
Helen was very young yet she had a
well-developed system of home signs
which could have been with the proper
teachers was somebody like baby aunt and
his successors turned her turned her
into a an even more remarkable woman a
genius than she was without the ability
to practice her own native language
those are interested there's a full
chapter on Helen and the language of
light and you all may find it
interesting thank you
okay sure there's one more question
there hi thank you um I have a question
a lot of hearing people especially
hearing parents now are finding you know
the advantages of using sign language
with infants right away after birth
because it's you know the the brain is
just going right from the beginning a
child is born and they're seeing the
importance of making connection to the
things that are in the world and it's
just so helpful for a child just you
know on the ratio of knowledge and my
question is I've seen children here that
never had a basic language like for
instance a child that might be in school
who really doesn't know sign language
who's deaf doesn't really understand
English even though they're trying to
teach that child English because at home
the family speaking Spanish so it seems
like if you're not if you're missing
your fundamental language foundational
language you're really at a disadvantage
and also with us you know with hearing
parents we're always talking to our
child so right away you know you know
it's putting on the jacket the booties
this is milk this is you know we're
constantly making a connection to things
for them to be able to you know gain
knowledge of their environment and I was
just curious when you were in Nicaragua
did you find any deaf parents with deaf
children or did you find families that
had many deaf members to be able to see
how they communicated if that
communication was so much better because
their children were getting right away
connections to the environment rather
than three years of delayed nothing no
language no fundamental language until
they got into school did you find any
families like that or is that something
you'd be interested in thank you
there are a few individuals who have
deaf relatives deaf aunts and so forth
and yes their language tends to be on a
par with what we would see in a
typically developing situation and you
absolutely have a rich environment
having a rich environment has a positive
impact on their language development one
thing I want to make sure that I
emphasize so often hearing parents who
have a deaf child have they're afraid
how will I learn sign language well
enough I can't possibly do that that's
not my language and that fear sometimes
drives them and there are multitude of
other reasons as well but it could drive
them to using spoken English
and I I didn't highlight this in my talk
but a lot of what we know is that
children are prodigious language
learners and they often will surpass
their input
so really the message that we want to
send to parents is that anything helps
learning sign with your kid helps their
language development that's what's
that's been shown so don't underestimate
what the kid has and what they can do
right and deaf families in Nicaragua are
quite rare I actually don't know of any
one who's taking a look at counting that
we know of a few but there aren't many I
feel like there's more here in the
United States but I could be wrong
I don't think there's ever been a count
done but in Nicaragua I certainly don't
know of many but a couple yes
okay last question I already spoke so
I'm happy to give up the mic to someone
who hasn't
why don't you speak so the interpreters
can hear you okay I'll just talk so I
have a couple questions my first one
being as two highly successful deaf
women how do you go about facing
prejudice in the workplace I mean that's
just really fascinating to me I'm a coda
and so I kind of have experience seeing
that prejudiced I'm just wondering I
mean I'm so so happy that you guys are
here I don't know I'm just interested in
that how do you would you advice about
counteracting that prejudice and things
like that
sorry that's so much yes it's okay in
many different ways all the time maybe
it would be helpful if you are curious
about if we're currently facing that
prejudice as adults or when we were
younger because my answer would be
different in those two contexts do you
mean you guys are both working at high
ranking institutions do you feel like
you still experience that okay sorry
that's a bad question it's fine okay
yes I can say a couple of things yes I
do experience things like that also I
have created a space for myself at my
current place of employment where I make
it work for me I make it that way
intentionally for myself and also I have
support from colleagues in my workplace
so to be honest I think I have a pretty
good place of employment where my
colleagues are supportive of me and my
work and they listen to what I have to
say about what I need and they basically
allow me to design the system there that
I want that works for me and I think
it's partly because well quite honestly
I don't know why that is but I do feel
that there are just good people there
just I'll briefly add one thing this
goes back to the intro of this panel I'm
lucky that I'm in the field that I'm in
that appreciates the importance of sign
language not only socially but on an
intellectual and academic level I'm also
lucky because my institution has a lot
of resources to support me in that work
but in that environment being in an
environment where people really are
appreciative of the study of sign
language like you all are that helps a
lot and that's fine and that's why I
really thank you all for hosting this
wonderful event thank you thank you
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]